So, if you would just start by introducing yourself, let us know your name, the date, and where we got, I don't know.
Okay.
I'm Christopher Matthews.
Today is September 2nd, 2011, and we're in the Valley Memorial Library.
Okay.
So, first of all, where are you born and right to go?
I was born in 1937 in New York City.
And my father was about to start a medical practice in the Bridgeport, Connecticut.
So, we moved from New York very early.
He was stationed with a Navy during the war on a variety of places.
And moved to Seattle in 1944, and the family moved with him after the war.
And my family moved back to Connecticut again, but after three years, they realized they'd made a big mistake leaving the West Coast.
So, we moved to Olympia in 1949, and that's what I consider my hometown.
But we're some of your hobby being here going in.
Well, it was pretty interesting science, obviously.
I had a chemistry set.
And my friends and I used to make rockets and fire them off.
And it became interested in birding a nature study because my grandfather was a professional,
or an anthologist who was cured, or birds at the American Museum of Natural History in New York.
So, we were very much exposed to natural history all my life.
And that's kept on.
I was president of the Audubon Society of Corvallas for three years.
So, there was a strong family influence in the science, and kind of understand where that early interest in science came from.
Right.
Well, yes.
My grandfather, of course, was an orthologist and a very broadly based biologist.
My father was a physician and his father was a surgeon.
So, there wasn't, well, let's say there was both medical and scientific.
It's even in our background.
And people who says natural, I guess, for me to have a career in science.
Oh, I did consider medicine pretty strongly.
I had various times.
That was another.
My mother?
She has a degree from vaster in English and actually dramatic production.
And she never got involved in science, but she obviously encouraged what my brother and my sisters and I did.
My brother ended up as a wildlife biologist in retired a few years ago from the University of Washington.
Faculty and the College of Fisheries.
My sisters are all younger, and they, two of them finished college, but they finished in their 30s.
My parents went through a fairly messy divorce.
One of my sisters were teenagers, and I think this kept them from being motivated to go through college,
but they were all very bright, and they went back.
And that achieved quite a lot actually.
My youngest sister, among other things, has published three books.
One of which was described her experience as the winner of the Pillsbury Bake Off in 1998,
with a $1 million prize.
It's a very readable book.
Very interesting.
So outside of your family, were there other scientific mentors or influences in your life?
I guess so.
I hadn't thought very much about that, but not so much toward the hard science.
In fact, the chemistry course that I took in high school is probably my least favorite course,
although the teacher, Mr. Gaines, was my merit badge counselor.
When I got the chemistry merit badge in Boy Scout, this is my freshman year in high school,
and he told me I shouldn't try for it till I was a junior, and I had taken chemistry.
And he helped me through it.
But he wasn't very good teachers.
And the botany teacher, Mr. Burke, also, and the physics teacher,
Mr. Keller, none of them I thought were particularly good teachers,
but there was enough interest in what I was doing,
and I guess that provided some motivation.
So it's got something to do with the involvement?
Yes.
When we moved to Olympia, we lived in right in town, actually, about two blocks from the state capital building,
and it was very easy to be in Boy Scouts.
And my parents bought some water from land about seven miles out of town,
and we moved there to a house that they built in my freshman year,
and they came much more difficult to be involved in scouting after that.
So although I always wanted to be an ego scouting, I just drifted out of it.
How do you characterize the rest of your high school experience?
Well, that's an interesting question too.
I had skipped the second grade, so I was younger and smaller than most of my classmates,
and it took me a while to catch up socially, but I worked pretty hard at it,
and ended up with a very nice group of friends.
I thought that the educational and high school experience was pretty mediocre.
I was maybe I was too hard on it.
I worked pretty hard, and obviously did pretty well.
My daughter managed to make it through a Corvallis High in three years,
and some, when I thought back on my high school experience,
and maybe that would have been good, but then I would have been two years ahead,
and the catching up socially would have been that much more difficult.
Any asked for it?
I've never been very athletic.
But I enjoy doing things, skiing, cross-country skiing,
and I jog regularly, and then you wouldn't call that athletics,
but it's keeping a shape, played a little tennis,
but it never was very good at much of anything in the way of sports.
Okay, so after high school, you went to read college,
how did you inside of your university?
Well, I was reading an article on the Saturday evening post in 1952,
my junior year in high school, and there was an article by Richard Newberger,
who later became a senator from Oregon.
And the title of the article was the school for bright young things,
and I guess that's sort of what I perceived myself as,
and I never heard of read college before even though we lived just 120 miles away from Portland.
And it looked like a pretty exciting place,
and it seemed as though it would be bright for me.
And so I applied to read, and I applied to Stanford.
And of course, it was accepted both places,
and read just so much more convenient, and it was more affordable.
Quite a different, quite a distinction between the two alternatives,
because our son eventually went to Stanford, so I learned a lot more about it.
I was in that you mentioned being some of this asked by the actor,
by the high school read, probably presented a different study.
Yeah, actually three of us from my graduating class went to read,
and one of them, only made it two years,
the other one, who's been a very strong science student,
ended up majoring in philosophy and going to law school,
and also becoming an extremely accomplished folk musician.
He and his wife basically made their living.
So read was interesting, in terms of the fact that a lot of people went there,
moving in one direction and changed directions completely,
or underrected them and getting a direction.
There was also a very high attrition rate then,
so there were a number of students that went there, underrected,
and there wasn't much supervision, and so a number of students just dropped up.
And I was one of the ones who had a sort of a vague idea of what I wanted to do,
and basically stayed with it.
What was the kind of life that we did in the day?
I suppose pretty much like it is today, it was pretty intense and largely,
but the students knew how to have a good time as well.
The academic environment was very strong.
The courses in liberal arts and social science,
all had a very heavy writing component.
So in the freshman humanities course, we had to write a paper every week,
and then we had an individual conference about every paper with the instructor.
Anything, any credit I can take for my ability to write today,
I owe to recalls, and the science was very strong.
Also, at that time, in the early mid-50s,
I would say that the science wasn't as strong as it is currently.
We'd like many of the other high quality undergraduate colleges
has really made a push for a stronger research orientation
in the science faculty, and although we were all required to write a thesis
when I would say the thesis weren't all cutting edge science.
Let's put it that way.
In fact, one of my regrets about read was that I probably took more science
than I really needed to, and I should have taken more courses
in liberal arts philosophy and literature and social sciences than I did.
But I ended up with the interest in a lot of different areas
and tend to learn a lot of things through my own reading,
and that's what college is supposed to be for anyway, I think.
How would you say you're assigned to the interest
developed within the graduate?
Well, I went there as a chemistry major because probably because of my interest
that started with the reading about chemistry and playing the chemistry sets
and so forth, so it was sort of an unfocused interest.
But at some point, I read a science fiction anthology of short stories
and the stories were grouped by scientific area
that the science fiction dealt with.
And so there were two or three stories that were listed under biochemistry
and I never heard a biochemistry before and I thought, hey,
the idea of chemistry that has something to do with biology,
I'm going to have to read these stories and I enjoyed them.
And so my junior year, I took a biochemistry course
and the reading I did both in class and out of class convinced me
that this was a pretty exciting area to go into.
During my sophomore year, I'd wrestled with the idea of going to medical school.
I had a hard time with organic chemistry, the first term of it
and the first in the fall term when I saw him over here.
And I'd like to tell medical students or pre-medical students the story.
I began to wonder if I was bright enough to go into science
and maybe I should go into medicine instead.
But then the second semester of the main course for majors was quantitative analysis.
And I did much better at the end of the year.
I decided I wasn't bright enough to go into science after all.
But was it that your reading or maybe your high school diploma
and story about a medical student at the very last point?
You think that?
My first herd of line is calling the fall semester
of my freshman year in chemistry class one day.
There was a student who raised his hand to ask a question.
And he said, oh, professor, does what you're talking about
if anything to do with the falling theory of resonance?
And professor, a little more gave him a very respectful answer.
And I thought to myself, I've never heard of falling.
But I guess I'd better learn something about this guy.
And then remarkably enough within the next two or three weeks,
it was announced that the line is falling
at one of the Nobel Prize in chemistry.
So I realized that the student was a little bit ahead of me
in terms of knowing major scientific teams.
And he said, let me read a letter.
Right.
I guess you when I talked about that a few years ago,
you all made it described that for the Oregonian
published editorial a day or two after the Nobel Prize
was announced.
It was basically congratulations to a native son of Oregon
who went on and achieved their great things.
And one of the Nobel Prize was in the same
about his inaccurate thinking and his political association
that had led him to have his passport lifted.
And I thought it was pretty inappropriate to bring these political things
into at a time when we should be celebrating this person's intellectual
triumph.
And so I wrote my first letter to the editor ever.
And at that time, Reed College was in very bad
and odor in the Portland area because the Valley Committee,
which was the House on American Activities Committee,
had toured the country in the spring,
just before I started college.
And three members of the Reed faculty were interviewed
and refused to discuss their associations.
And this made a lot of people think that Reed was full of communists.
So when I wrote the letter to the editor,
I used my home address from Malookia,
which could be seen as being within the
readership area of Oregon.
And then, I guess I clicked the editorial
and my letter and mailed them home to my mother.
And because my grandparents knew the poems,
my grandfather was a member of the American Philosophical Society,
which Pauline was also,
my mother mailed this to my grandmother,
and my grandmother mailed it to Pauline.
And Pauline eventually sent me a nice sort of note,
which pleased me a great deal.
Pauline's youngest son, Crelon, was a classmate of mine at Reed.
And then, later on,
when I was a graduate student at the University of Washington,
and my wife was a graduate student in genetics.
Crelon Pauline was doing his graduate work in genetics also.
So Kate and Crelon worked in the same lab,
and we used to see them socially, fairly frequently.
So somehow or another,
I had a fairly close series of relationships with the Pauline family.
That's a good idea about that.
Can you reflect on the time of Crelon?
I'm sorry.
Yeah, he was pretty immature.
And he had a great sense of humor.
He seemed to enjoy life a lot.
He started as a chemistry major at Reed,
and he didn't do very well.
So he switched to biology,
and it took him five years to graduate.
So he started graduate school at UW a year after I had,
and then I think it took him five or six years to finish his PhD.
But he actually published some fairly important papers
from his postdoc, and then later on,
when he was on the faculty at San Francisco State,
as far remember, he was chair of the biology department there
for quite a few years.
And so he was always very likable fellow.
And he was on sabbatical here in 1980 and 81.
And he worked with Dick Marita and the microbiology department.
And his then second wife, K-Paul,
and worked in art department as a postdoc,
with one of my colleagues.
So we established contact.
And it was very close.
I didn't know anything.
But it was kind of amusing.
This doesn't have any to do with college era.
But during that year that Crelon Pauling was here,
I was called upon to be the organizer of the,
what used to be the annual biology colloquium.
I'm not even sure if that's still held.
So I organized the two-day meeting on the organization
and manipulation of genetic information.
This is 1981.
And we had a party for the speakers and the people participating.
And the president, McVicker, was at the party,
and he came up to me and he said,
Chris, I'd like to have you introduce me to wine as Pauling Sun.
So I took him over and introduced him to Crelon.
And he backed Crelon into a corner and wouldn't let him out.
And they were talking there for probably 20 minutes.
I was trying to think of a way that I could rescue Crelon,
but it didn't work.
So did you have any wine as Pauling?
With wine as Pauling?
Yes.
Probably the first time I met him.
He came to Seattle for a lecture.
And I met him there.
So that would have been in 1961 when I was a student.
But then my first month here,
I started my appointment as chairman of biochemistry
and bio physics in January 1978.
And one of the first things I learned in my first week on the job
was that I had to get ready for sight visit for our department.
Because the legislature, in the previous year,
had made some sort of a budget and order or some kind,
that there should be reviews of academic programs
that might involve duplication between Oregon State and the U of O.
And although the U of O didn't have a biochemistry department,
they had the Institute of Molecular Biology and the Head of Biology
to Harvard and the Chemistry of Harvard.
The chemistry and biochemistry were getting reviewed.
And Linus Pauling was one of the outside reviewers that was brought in.
And it was fairly intimidating.
So I had to prepare for a day-long sight visit.
I've forgotten who the other reviewers were.
And then we had a similar experience.
If we were sight visit, there's a biology department as well.
So I had to organize two sight visits.
And I remember the biology site visit.
One of the site visitors was the Herschel Roman
who was professor of genetics at the UW.
And he used the one that my wife worked for.
And one of the other sight visitors was the guy named Gordon Lark,
who was a Kansas State University.
He was quite a prominent bacterial geneticist.
And when he met with me early on the morning,
he said, Chris, why did you move here anyway?
And sort of a sort of a wondering what the deal was.
What was the attraction?
Because I had a pretty good job at the University of Arizona before.
I moved here.
And then later in the day, when I met with him again,
and they had a chance to talk to a lot of other people,
and learn about Oregon State.
You don't have to answer me anymore.
He said, no, I know why you moved here.
So I felt pretty good about the decision I had,
and I had to move when that happened.
That gets over the way from line is falling.
But I met him two or three times when he came to the campus,
either for the annual award of the Pauling Medal,
or for other things.
Somehow we were brought into contact.
So I probably met him half a dozen times.
Did I ever tell you the story about Pauling and the joke that he told?
At the Pauling.
Do you want to hear that?
It gets a little bit out of the chronology.
So the three north-western sections of the American Chemical Society
give the line is Pauling Medal over a year,
they jointly.
And there's a symposium on a banquet
and the local moves around from Corvallos to Seattle
to the Plum and Washington or wherever.
And in the fall of 1979 it was held here.
And so Pauling used to come to all these.
And after the banquet then he would give a little talk about
what he'd been doing during the previous year.
These things were always hugely entertaining.
And so the talk that he gave in 1979
and Mrs. Pauling was with him.
He used to a lot of them.
He said that he was encountering a lot of skepticism about
Vitamin C and the reporter was interviewing.
And he said now Professor Pauling,
you take Vitamin C, don't you?
Of course I do real man.
Well, then sir, do you mind if I ask you a few questions about your
state of vigor?
No, go right ahead.
Well sir, can you tell me then please?
What did you have your last sexual experience?
Well I looked at him and I said why in 1956?
And he said, well that's terrible.
And I said, what's a terrible voter?
And he looked at his watch and said,
it's only 22-10 now.
Okay, well feedback to your life.
So we mentioned at Washington and then Seattle.
How do you make decisions in those?
Okay, that's a good question too.
In the summer of 1957, I went back to visit my grandparents
in Long Island and they were very interested in having
me go to graduate school in the East Coast.
So they took me to visit various schools,
Harvard and Brown and Johns Hopkins.
But one thing that I did since they lived fairly far out on the island,
they'd arranged a visit for me at Brookhaven National Laboratory.
And I met with a biochemist there named Robert Steele.
And he told me about what he was doing.
And he said, I don't know why you're looking at all of these
graduate schools in the East Coast when one of the best graduate
schools in the country is right out where you live.
And I said what's that?
And he said by the University of Washington,
it's a new department, but it's really good.
So I figured well, I guess I'd better look at it.
And so I ended up applying to Berkeley, Johns Hopkins,
and the University of Washington.
And in those days, 1953, 54, no excuse me,
57, 58, you didn't get flown to the department
to be interviewed at their expense.
I had visited Johns Hopkins.
I never did go down to the Cal.
But I was home for the weekend and drove up to Seattle.
And the department was small.
It had just seven faculty members.
But they were really nice.
And they represented a nice cross-section of the biochemist
for that era.
And they all had good records of academic achievement.
And it was pretty close to my family.
And all living in the state of Washington at the time.
And so I figured, why not?
And worked out pretty well.
Well, it was pretty on focus when I began graduate school.
When my fellow students would ask me,
what are you interested in?
I'd scratch my head and I'd say, well,
I guess I'm interested in enzymes.
But I'd like to do some project and enzymes that has potential
applications in medicine or biology.
What have you?
And so we were required to talk to all the faculty about their
research and the frankhonicons who was doing work on fully
enzymology.
It's a fully, it's one of the B vitamins.
And it's converted to a co-insan, tetrahhydrofolate.
And tetrahhydrofolate is a co-insan that mobilizes
a single carbon functional groups.
And so these are involved in methylation, for example,
methylation of DNA, methylation of certain amino acids and proteins.
And also, the methyl group of thymineucytides that get
into DNA.
And the hodicons laboratory had just recently shown that
the action of methyltrexate, which is a folate analogue,
used in cancer treatment.
He was discovered in the 1940s, it's a very potent anti-lucinic agent
that had acted by inhibiting an enzyme called
dihydrofolate productase that reduces folate tetrahhydrofolate.
And I thought this was really interesting.
There wasn't very much known about the enzyme at the time.
But the fact that the enzyme was a target for a very effective drug
meant that the whole area of folate and zymology had the kind of protein
enzyme focused that I was interested in with potential
applications of significant medicine.
So I went to work with the Harkonocons and it worked out pretty well
for me.
He was on age of professor.
One of the other reasons that I was interested in as lab was
that I learned that he'd had several students who managed
to finish their PhDs in fairly short order.
And I was interested in getting my PhD in moving on.
And that worked out pretty well too.
I completed my PhD requirements in a little under three
and a half years, which is pretty fast by today's standards,
where a PhD is generally a five-year program or so.
Well, as you, when you were at Harkonocons and work
in the PhDs, you did that many.
That's something you got married, that's what you're asking.
Yeah, that's an interesting one too, because my wife was a graduate
school classmate in biochemistry.
There were 12 entering students in the class of the
class of 1958.
And we ended up as lab partners in the lab course.
And then later in the year, as teaching assistants,
we were assigned together to the, to the reagent room.
It was called the solution room, making up reagents for the biochemistry
lab class for dental students.
And we were supposed to put in 10 hours a week of effort
on our TA duties.
And we worked pretty efficiently together.
So I think maybe we worked two or three hours each per week.
And we didn't see each other socially at all at the time.
She had a bunch of other boyfriends.
And I think we both had the feeling that you didn't get involved
with people that you saw every day.
But her interests were more biological.
And the genetics department was founded in the spring of 1959.
So she transferred to genetics in our second year.
One we were not seeing each other every day.
It became a little bit more natural on the.
And so we got married in the spring of early summer of 1960.
And it's kind of interesting because Kate grew up in Berkeley.
Her mother was a research technician in the virus lab.
She worked for Wendell Stanley who wanted Nobel Prize.
First, we're working to back him on Zaykh virus.
And at Berkeley, the virus lab and the biochemistry department.
We're in the same building at the time.
And Kate's mother tended to mother all the graduate students who were on a task.
So if I'd gone to Cal as a graduate student,
we've always wondered whether, whether Elsa would have sort of mothered me and
ticked me out of the someone suitable for her daughter.
And would have got us together.
And we had a laugh over that over the years.
But you can only live one life of the time.
We also had your first child as a natural candidate.
Right, that wasn't planned.
Lawrence was born maybe nine and a half months after we got married.
And the drank champagne from a glass on our first wedding anniversary.
And so Kate never finished her Ph.D.
And she claims, at various times, I encourage her to do it.
She worked as a lab technician.
And she also worked when I was at Yale.
She worked as a teaching assistant in the department of biology where I was.
And she always claimed that she really didn't want a Ph.D.
Anyway, she loves working in a lab and she's pretty good at it.
But she says she's good at the tactics, but not so good at the strategy.
Get developing a long range line of research and applying for funding.
And that sort of thing.
So I think she's pretty happy with the kind of careers she had.
Was it difficult to sort of make an household and also be sort of going to do a program these days?
Yeah.
Well, somehow it worked.
I a lot of my fellow students would go back to work in a lab in the evening and I just stay home.
And Kate was very good about after Lawrence was born about seeing that I had a couple of quiet hours every evening.
And I don't remember what's sitting around.
She was still working as a graduate student in a teaching assistant in the genetics department.
Somehow it's going to work.
Okay.
So you finished up your Ph.D.
You done when you did a postdoc at Penn.
I'm a little bit like that.
Yeah.
By the time I was approaching finishing my Ph.D.
I knew that I wanted to work in a biological system that had more potential for genetics.
I was getting more involved in the biological side of insology than the chemical or biophysical side and reading the literature.
I selected three people whose work I was interested in.
And I wanted to be able to go to a lab where the specific experience that I'd had as a graduate student would be useful.
And so Seymour Cohen at the University of Pennsylvania was the one I eventually settled on.
And he was working on bacteria phases.
That's your analysis.
And basically in the late 1940s when he started with his own lab.
He'd done what I would call the first biochemical experiments on what happens metabolically during a virus infection cycle.
Using cages model systems for plant or animal viruses, which of course were much more difficult to work with biochemically at that time.
And in the early 1950s he and a postdoc had shown that DNA from certain bacteria phases had a very unusual modification.
And that all of the cytosine residues in DNA were modified by having a hydroxymethyl group.
And then on the mid to late 1950s they'd shown the biochemical basis for this that there were new enzymes that were induced after a virus infection that put on the hydroxymethyl group.
And that phosphorylated the nucleotides that get us at the point where it could be activated and incorporated in the DNA.
So the whole idea that virus infections stimulated new metabolic pathways was really exciting to me.
And this enzyme to put on the hydroxymethyl group had a tetrahydrophobic co-facture.
So it meant that I could bring some biochemistry to a colon's lab that would be, that would be, that would help them out.
Because it was nice pairing. But again, in those days, now we're talking 1961.
You didn't just hop on a plane to visit every lab that you were going to consider for a postdoc.
So I wrote to three people.
And I was going to give a paper at the Federation meeting in 1961.
This is the Federation of American societies for experimental biology, which at that time included societies for biochemistry, physiology,
pharmacology, nutrition, and a couple of others.
And it was the big meeting for biochemists to go to.
And so the three people that I was considering would be at the meeting.
And I could meet with them there.
This happened very shortly after Lawrence was born.
So I really located that of gratitude and also my mother and Kate's mother.
And my grandmother, who all came in and helped out.
But I was able to go to the meeting and meet with them.
And it was kind of amusing because on the first day of the meeting, I met a Seymour Cohen for the first time.
And apparently my major professor, who had sent a letter of recommendation, sent a two-page letter.
And I didn't learn this to later.
But the second page of the letter to Cohen had Dr. Boyer's name at the top of the page.
And so Seymour knew that I was considering more than one laboratory.
And he had recently had someone very good who had accepted a postdoc.
And then went somewhere else and said, so almost as soon as I shook hands with Seymour and introduced myself.
He said, now she here, if I accept you in my laboratory, are coming or aren't you.
And so it really set me off.
And I'm wondering who is this guy anyway.
But then I met the other two people during that week and by the end of the week.
I decided I wanted to work with Seymour.
So I had another appointment with him.
And almost before I had a chance to say anything.
He said, well, I've decided I'd like to have you come and join my lab.
And I said, well, that's funny. I decided I want to join your lab too.
And then he insisted on driving me to Philadelphia.
This is an Atlantic city which is about 60 miles from Philadelphia.
So I could see his lab and meet the other people, which I did.
And that was very nice because then I knew them all by the time.
I joined his group, six or eight months later.
So from there, you were done to jail.
How did that find out?
And what was it like?
Think and bring exactly memory of your laboratory.
Things were much different back then.
I used to get unsolicited offers of assistant professors.
If they're not supposed to know offers, I'd get a letter in the mail from the department chairman that would say would
you like to apply for assistant professors in art department.
And see what I'm calling would come into the lab and occasion with letters.
You would like to, they want me to recommend someone for this place of that place.
Would you like to apply?
Most of the time I said, well, no.
But Yale was interesting.
My father had worked at the Yale Medical School after the war back in that interval
between our lives in Washington and State.
And I knew Yale was a pretty good place.
And so I told Seymour, he could go ahead and put my name in.
But I told him, I really hope to get back to the West Coast.
And he said, well, fine, I'll write to a couple of places where you like me to write.
And I said, well, you see Davis has a new biochemistry department.
You could write to that.
And also the University of Oregon has this new Institute of Molecular Biology.
They have some terrific people there.
So he wrote to both places.
And they both wrote back and said, they had positions.
And they were interested in, I should send my CV and so forth.
Which I did.
And the meantime, then I was invited up to Yale to be interviewed.
And it was an interesting day.
I gave the seminar at noon.
And then I met immediately after the seminar with the search committee.
And they gave me a lunch date, which I was trying to eat at the same time.
I was trying to answer a question.
So it was pretty stressful.
And one of the search committee members took me to the train at the end of the day.
And I went back to Philadelphia.
And he said, well, we have to go through a series of steps before we can make a decision.
And anything, but so maybe a while before you hear from us again.
And I thought, well, that's fine.
I'm not to hurry anyway, because I want to see what develops at Davis and Eugene.
But within a week, I had a letter from them saying that the search committee had met.
And they decided that they were going to recommend that I get the appointment.
And it's over.
And eventually, I did get a formal offer of a letter.
And I sort of stole them as long as I could.
And finally, it was a good offer.
The salary was pretty poor.
And by comparison with what my co-ord was getting at other places.
But it was the biology department.
And I didn't consider myself so much in biologists.
But they were trying to build up biochemistry and molecular biology within the department.
They wanted me to set up a lab class in biochemical research techniques that their graduate students could take.
That was a little bit of a challenge.
Anyway, I accepted the job on Monday.
And then I wrote to the department chairs at Eugene and Davis.
And then on Thursday, the phone rang in the lab.
And I took the call.
It was the department chair at the U of O.
And I said, oh, Dr. Matthews, we just got your letter.
And we're terribly disappointed.
We got your last recommendation in.
The faculty had a meeting.
We decided you'd be ideal for the job.
We were about to invite you to come out and give a seminar.
Can we get you to change your mind?
And I said, I'm sorry.
I didn't pay to commit that.
That was that.
And then I went home thinking, I guess I'd give it up my last chance to go to a good university in the Pacific Northwest.
And who would have known what happened years later.
So I went to Yale in starting in January, 1964.
And today's assistant professors, of course, got almost the first year without significant teaching responsibilities.
To set up their lab.
And the very first thing I had to start setting up to teach this lab class,
that was beginning the end of the, well, the beginning of the spring semester, which is the end of January,
that really February.
And I had ordered almost everything I needed.
But a teaching assistant, and I had to set up the lab.
I had to write the protocols for all the labs that the students would do.
And I had a class of 15 students.
So I was very busy with teaching.
On the other hand, I also had my NIH research grant that started on January 1st.
Grants were incredibly easy to get back then.
And so I was buying equipment and hiring a technician and getting my research labs set up at the same time.
It was sort of a continuation of what I'd done as a postdoc.
One of the things, this is actually kind of an amusing story, too.
The thesis of my PhD thesis had been on the enzyme,
I'm done hydrofolate reductase, which I told you was the target enzyme for the method structure.
And there was another lab that had shown the enzyme that makes the methyl group of thymine,
reduces the methylene group to the methyl level.
That requires two electrons.
And the rate of DNA synthesis after T4 phase infection goes up by about tenfold,
which means there's a tremendous demand for DNA precursors, including thymine nucleotides.
And so since there's a two electron reduction, it turns out that the tetrahedrofolate is oxidized, the dihydrofolate.
And so when I became aware of all this, and I was talking to Seymar Cohen one day on the lab,
and I said, you know, this big increase in demand for thymine nucleotides,
they're all these virus induced enzymes that you and the other labs have been discovering.
We should be looking for dihydrofolate reductase.
There should be a virus specific form of dihydrofolate reductase as well.
I know how to assay the enzyme. I worked on it for my PhD.
So as I go ahead and do that.
And he said, why did you focus on the problem that we agreed that you would work on
when you came to the lab and I said, okay.
And then Seymar was out of town for three days or so.
And I did the experiment.
And there was a 24th increase in the specific activity of dihydrofolate reductase.
And in T-fage infected cells is compared to on infected cells.
And it turned out to be really easy to show that it was a different enzyme from the,
of course, wanting enzyme that existed in the on infected bacteria.
So one of the things I did, we got a short paper out of it.
But one of the things that I did when I went to Yale was just a,
it was a golden opportunity to get a free paper.
We just to purify the enzyme and characterize it.
Make mutants that were deficient in the production of the enzyme to see what their phenotype was and so far.
So there were a number of problems related to DNA precursor metabolism,
particularly in infection by T even.
The fact you were very just that got me off to a pretty decent start.
And I published the six or eight papers in the first couple of years.
I was at the Yale, even though I had a pretty heavy teaching load.
So you were a Yale for four years, definitely.
Roughly, actually three and a half by the calendar.
But they started my appointment as assistant professor in July of 1963.
I was in a sense for the first half year.
And then I taught that lab class.
And then in the fall, they had me set up a lab for the,
what was an undergraduate cell biology course,
which was basically biochemistry in the fall semester and cell biology and the spring semester.
So a colleague and I shared the fall course where he did most of the lecturing.
I taught the lab.
And then in the year, research is in the change.
And of course, you had kind of yellow.
Were you sitting with that same faculty?
Oh, about research?
Yeah.
Yeah, I stayed pretty much with that.
I was branching out a little bit more biologically.
And looking at questions such as the regulation,
the time-specific regulation, gene expression,
virus infection involves a very well-scheduled program of events
and gene activation and deactivation.
And so I was interested in what turns off the biosynthesis.
These are really enzymes that are involved in DNA metabolism.
And then the activation of the late proteins,
which are mostly structural proteins of the virus,
and proteins that help the virus assemble.
So I was pretty much sticking with what I knew,
but branching out in slightly different directions.
What was your sense of the culture, Yale?
Yeah, that's an interesting question too.
It was all male, of course, as far as the undergraduate or student body was concerned.
There was a fair amount of self-satisfaction.
The undergraduate or students who were really bright,
at least enough of them were really bright to make it worth the effort to teach them.
The graduate students seemed like kind of a mixed lot to me.
I wasn't hugely impressed with them at the time,
except for some of the very good ones.
And what's turned out in retrospect is that I maybe was a little bit too hard of them,
because a number of the graduate students that I thought were okay,
have turned out to have very successful careers.
I see their names and all the time.
So I guess the students were, they were as good as they thought they were.
But in terms of the culture,
by decision to leave Yale after a fairly short period there,
it was hasten.
I knew what I went there, I wouldn't have my whole career there.
I didn't really want to live in the East Coast.
I knew that most people would take non-tender jobs
in the Ivy League, move somewhere else.
And I thought it was a great place to start from.
I might not have left so early, but we had a new department here
who came from Johns Hopkins.
And he was a fairly argumentative sort.
He was someone who always wanted to put himself on the,
he wanted to polarize discussions.
And so in my last year at Yale,
the other biochemist in the department had gone on sabbatical
and no arrangements that had been made to take his place.
So I was giving all of his lectures and the cell biology course
that I was teaching the lab in the fall
and then teaching the graduate lab in the spring.
And in addition, I'd become a premedical advisor.
So I had several dozen advisees that I had to meet with
and write letters of recommendation for.
And I was being run ragged and trying to keep my research going as well.
So there was a social function.
And I went up to the departments here.
There was a large department there about 45 people in the department.
So he barely knew me.
And I engaged in a conversation.
I asked him, what are your thoughts about teaching
versus research and an academic environment?
And he said, well, of course you had to do a good teacher
if you want to succeed at Yale, but the main objective was
to make sure she said if you want to say a Yale,
you research must settle it.
It must absolutely settle it.
And if you ever want to be a full professor of Yale in this department,
you have to be someone that we can confidently number
among the top 50 biologists in the country.
So I went home and I figured with the amount of teaching
and committee work I was doing, there wasn't any chance
of my rising to the top 50.
And then I also looked around the department.
And I didn't see very many full professors that I would rank
in the top 50 myself, there were one or two.
So that has something to do with the culture, I guess.
So you mentioned the 1967 movement Arizona?
Right, that came about because the department
here at Arizona had been one of my professors at the
University of Washington.
He was on my committee.
He was someone I liked a lot.
And he called me up one day and told me
that the University of Arizona had a new medical school
starting and that he just agreed to be chairman
of the biochemistry department and what I liked
and joined him.
And I knew nothing about Arizona at the time.
But I liked his name with Tom Hanahan,
and he was in an area of biochemistry that's quite different
from mine.
He was an expert on biochemistry, fats and lipids.
And the idea of starting something new.
And there wasn't a matter of being interviewed
of search committees that are now a guy
that had basically just offered me a job over the phone.
And then I arranged to go out and visit.
This was in January, 1967.
And Kate went with me and we had to pay her expenses.
And it was just a wonderful time.
They put us up in a nice place.
And we got up in the morning and stepped out the front door.
I picked a great fruit for our breakfast off.
The tree that was going right next to our front door.
And the dean and his wife took us out the dinner one night.
And in my years at Yale, I never met my dean.
The dean of the faculty of arts and sciences.
And here was the dean taking us out of the dinner
and telling me how much they hoped that I would decide
to go there.
It was a promotion break to be an associate professor.
Big increase in salary.
And the opportunity to help shape something
because the medical school was brand new.
Every one in Arizona was excited about the medical school
that was starting.
And it just seemed like the right thing to do.
And did it about the education?
Yes.
I really enjoyed the time that we spent there.
We were there for ten and a half years.
And there was a lot of excitement in the first few years
having the feeling that we were helping to build the place up.
The medical school there was maybe half a mile from the main campus.
Maybe a quarter mile.
It was a five-minute bike ride or a ten-minute walk.
And there was a little biochemistry group in the chemistry department.
There was pretty good.
And a daughter part of the medical school was small.
We had, I think, five or six faculty at the whole time.
I was there.
And so we merged and formed a joint graduate committee
and biochemistry.
So that was one of the things that I felt was a contribution
on my part in the part of Don Hannahand.
That we wanted to build bridges to the main campus
or as in other fields like microbiology.
They were barriers that were built up.
And the bridges, I think, really were beneficial to the university.
And now they have a combined university-wide department that serves
the main campus people and the medical school people.
And mostly located on the main campus.
I think there are a couple of people left in the medical school building
that focused on medical education.
So you were obligation-stained with friends on the old areas on that?
Yes, they did.
Of course teaching medical students was quite a different experience.
But I did also teach courses on the main campus
and mostly the advanced undergraduate graduate level course
and some colleagues and I originated some graduate level courses.
I don't think I did any graduate teaching
or Yale except for the graduate lab class.
So I taught courses in biological regulatory mechanisms
and nucleic acids and so forth as well as teaching
undergraduates and medical students.
But overall, I think the teaching load was a little bit,
I hate that term, teaching load of the teaching obligation.
Teaching opportunity was a little bit lighter
than what it was ideal.
And so there was a little bit more time to get involved in research.
And again, there was building the department,
recruiting other faculty members, beginning to include graduate students
and getting funding for graduate students' support
and so forth.
Yeah, it was a different experience.
So what kind of, what was your line of research
for students in the graduate lab class?
Well, I continued with some of the projects
that were underway when I left Yale
and picked up some new ones.
But for the most part, they had to do with
the end zymology and regulation of DNA precursors.
One thing that happened was that
people involved in T4 by Terry Fage genetics
had generated a large number of mutants
that were available.
And there were mutants in maybe 15 genes
that were involved in DNA synthesis.
And it wasn't clear what the biochemical functions
all these genes coded for.
And so I got involved in that a little bit
to what extent do we run?
Might some of the genes have to do with DNA precursors
and metabolism and to what extent might they have to do
with DNA replication itself.
And so at some stage, I became interested
in the relationship between the synthesis of the
four DNA precursors, AGC and T,
to make it simplest.
And the replication apparatus,
because DNA replication is a very rapid process.
It's in bacteria or in phase attack
of bacteria.
The DNA chain will grow at something like
seven or eight hundred duplicatized per second.
So I started thinking, how can the enzymes
that are making the precursors throughout the cell?
How can they channel precursors to DNA polymerase
that replication apparatus fast enough
to sustain this rate?
So I started working on the premise
that there was a super molecular
organization within the infected cell
with the precursor enzymes physically
located close to the replist on the machinery
that synthesized the DNA,
so that you could get channeling
of precursors to the DNA replication sites.
And that was a pretty big part of my research.
For several of the years I was there,
I was only going to try quite a bit of the time
that I was here.
But we picked up some lines of research
on comparable questions
and in mammalian cells,
which can ensure culture.
I also had a couple of students
who worked on CCs quite independently
on things that were quite different
from anything that I did.
One of them was sure that aging
was a question of gene expression
and that you should be able to learn something about
aging if you do something about the kinetics
of nucleic acid metabolism.
And he did a thesis that was partly
computational, partly biochemical
on RNA metabolism that he published,
one paper he published independently
and one paper he put my name on
as a courtesy gesture.
And after I came here,
he joined my lab again.
He had a grant and he wanted to
he needed a site that he could work
or he could work fairly independently.
I remember that I'd let him have his own head.
So he was here for a couple of years.
And then he got the idea of
adolescence as a potential drug
and founded a company called
Antivirals and as a recreation room here in Corvals.
And then that turned into ultimately
an avioid bio farmer,
which is about technology company in Corvals.
And eventually he left them
and formed another company,
gene tools,
which is in full almost,
and it's hugely successful.
So even though all I provided
was a supporting environment at Arizona,
it's turned out having a very nice
spin-off here.
We're at about an hour.
Are you going to know, okay?
Yeah, fun.
So this is your very brief experience
of the Southwest.
And you mentioned the experiences
that can be great for the Southwest.
We really enjoyed living there.
And both Kate and I are pretty enthusiastic
outdoors people.
And we found out that there's a lot more
variety in Arizona than we ever
believed there was.
Tucson is bring by four mountain ranges.
We did a lot of backpacking there.
And we went camping in Mexico.
It turned out there were some very nice
beach areas on the Gulf of California
that we went camping at.
And so we really did everything we could
to enjoy and profit from the Southwest.
And we missed a lot of that.
We missed being able to get into the outdoors
12 months of the year very easily.
But Tucson was growing with very little planning.
And Tucson is one of the largest cities in the world
that gets all of its water from underground.
And when the chance came to come to come here.
Of course, it was professionally a very nice opportunity.
We were helping Tucson.
I wonder, do we really want to move?
But one of the features was how much longer
is it going to make up water sustain the population?
How much longer are we going to have
these beautiful desert environments that
really state the developments are crowding onto?
So that all convinced us that we really enjoyed
the 10 years there.
But maybe it was time to go.
And every time we go back to Tucson,
we're horrified that the additional growth
that's occurred.
You took this a battle over this.
UCSD in 1973.
Right.
Kate still criticizes me on occasion
for not having taken a European sabbatical end
because our children were something like 12 and 14
at the time.
And they probably really would have profit
from a year in Europe.
But I still had a fairly small research group
and wanted to stay in reasonable close
touch with them.
And of course UCSD was a growing
academic environment with some superb people.
And we live near the B.
So it was a very nice living for the year.
I split the year between two different laboratories.
So I had two different kinds of experiences
and it was very nice.
It was a good sabbatical.
What did you do there?
The false semester or the fall.
The first six months I worked with a guy named Gordon Sato,
who was an expert on culturing cells
and maintaining their differentiated characteristics
in culture.
And I wanted to learn tissue culture
because I wanted to be able to branch out
with our interest in the million systems.
So I could take what we were learning in microbial
model systems and apply them to a million
or maybe human systems.
So I wanted to learn tissue culture.
So I did a project I could have to do with
with growth factors in cell culture.
And then in the second six months I went
to the script's institutional biography
while I had a very good friend who was an expert
on the biochemistry of early events
in fertilization using the sea urchin.
And so fertilization is a little comparable
to the phagian effect of the metabolic change
that occurs as a huge turn on of DNA synthesis
and the cleavage cycle of the cell cleavage cycles
are very fast.
So DNA genomes are reproduced
and of the order of half an hour.
And so the question in my mind was
where do the precursors come from?
Are they stored or are they turned out of synthesis?
So that was what I worked on in Dave's lab
and it turned out that the sea urchin egg has
huge supplies of the oxenucleusid triphosphates
and then backup pools of the monophosphates
and the triphosphates.
The egg is really geared to activate the DNA
such as a very soon after fertilization.
And I thought about going back and working with that
system a little bit of my own after I came here
but never got around to it.
There are plenty of other things to do.
What's fantasy straight down there?
No, I don't think so.
Yeah, he was been at the sockets
to not forgotten when he moved.
There I should know that because I reviewed
the biography of France as quick as a few months ago
for a journal in Dave's fascinating reading.
It was all this book.
In my review, I wrote that this,
I've been asked to review quite a few scientific books over the years.
This is the first one I actually read.
Word, cover, cover, cover.
This readbook and all, but I'm pretty sure that was before
Kirk and move to saw it.
I was that right?
I was that right.
Because I knew the name already.
I knew he was a famous historian of science,
the recent historian of science.
See Mark Cohen was very interested in the really history of molecular biology.
He was pretty unpopular with the crowd in that field
because he was so aggressively pro biochemical
and didn't necessarily believe in genetics.
And see Mark Cohen was the first graduate
that was student of Erwin Chargaff.
Chargaff who had promulgated the base to the composition
and regularities that helped Watson and Quick develop their model.
And Chargaff had been very bitter about being left out of credit
for that.
And I think similar shared Chargaff's bitterness to some extent.
And so when the Nobel Prize was announced,
I was in Seymour's Laban.
There's in 1962.
And it went to Watson and Quick and Maurice Wilkins.
And so Seymour came into the lab and said,
well, if they were going to include Wilkins and the Nobel Prize,
they should have included Chargaff because his contribution
was just as substantial.
And I think you can make a pretty good case for that.
Of course, the Nobel Prize is limited to three awardees.
So I'm sure that didn't do very much for Erwin Chargaff's mood either.
But he was at the base for the candidate for the guy.
Yeah, he was.
In fact, Chargaff was the one who got me started thinking about Seymour Cohen
because my second year in graduate school,
Chargaff came to Seattle and gave a series of lectures.
And during the lectures, he talked about virus induced enzyme.
He talked about work by done by, quote,
my student Seymour Cohen, unquote.
And so immediately went to the literature,
started reading Seymour Cohen's papers.
I'd never heard of him before.
And that was what got me fired up.
And the fact that Seymour was,
Erwin Chargaff's student,
but at some point, I met the guy that was the chairman of Biochemistry
at Columbia when Chargaff had moved from Europe.
I think he was a refugee.
And Columbia took him in.
And so the chairman, whose name was Hans Clark,
he was quite a distinguished Biochemistry.
He told me what you're doing to our community.
And I said, well, I'm a post-doc in the University of Pennsylvania.
Oh, who are you working with?
I'm working with Seymour Cohen.
Oh, yes, Seymour.
He's one of my boys, you know.
He was very paternal or paternalistic.
And so Seymour was, Erwin Chargaff's student.
But it turned out that when Seymour was working on his post-doc,
or on his PhD,
neither of them was working in a black ass at the time.
So Seymour has PhD thesis on long surfactant,
which is a phospholipid.
And it wasn't until years later that both Chargaff and Cohen
independently started working on the black ass at Biochemistry.
So there's something kind of fascinating about
the personalities involved in the recent history of science.
Yeah.
Cohen told me he was definitely in pretty big figure in the life.
He was, you know, he taught the famous course in comparative biochemistry.
I don't remember who I never sat in on the course.
I should have.
But he was very broadly based.
He was very rigorous in his thinking.
So I mean, he had a pretty prickly personality.
So so he was definitely a challenge to work for.
But he was so broad and he had so many ideas that I think
influenced me to to read pretty widely in science.
And in trying to maintain it broad awareness.
That's helping a lot in writing a textbook.
And also since I became a number of the editorial board of the Journal of Biological
Chemistry, I get sent papers to review that are way way outside of my area.
Because editors know that I can sit down and read something.
I got a paper review a couple of years ago on the Biochemistry
Body Order, if you believe that.
Well, we refer to this a little bit.
In 1970, we used OEC and it sounds like they made a pretty good opportunity.
And that's the primary reason.
Right.
There was an interesting situation too.
I didn't have any real reasons to leave Arizona.
As I said, you can always find things to feel uneasy about.
But I felt pretty well, accepted on the campus.
But I said, my family was all still in the Pacific Northwest.
And so I kept my eye out for opportunities.
And OEC advertised for a chair of the Department of Biochemistry
and Biophysics and Science.
So I wrote sent by CV.
And eventually it was asked for my reference as always.
It sent the names of references.
And eventually it was asked to interview.
And I had enough information about the departments.
And I know that it was a pretty good department.
And they sent me the data on the research funding of the faculty.
And there were 14 faculty at the time.
And everyone except one had some kind of outside research funding.
Publication records looked pretty good.
So on the days when I was interviewed, it was a two-day or two-and-a-half-day process.
I had a series of half-hour talks with the faculty.
And each one, I would say, you know, you got a good department.
Why are you looking outside for your chair?
You could, you could fill the chairmanship inside.
And I got told pretty much the same thing by everyone.
And of course, when you get consistency, that's a pretty good sign.
And what they said was, this is our only chance to bring in a senior
level faculty person who can bring out a funded research program
and give a jump start to our departments reputation.
Because if we appointed an inside person to chair them,
we'd have to fill the vacancy assistant professor level.
So that made sense.
And they said that the department was in pretty good shape scientifically.
And personally everyone got along, which really seemed to be the case.
And so what they wanted was someone who was a pretty active scientist and teacher
who was willing to do some administration and leadership.
And that was sort of how I saw myself.
I knew by that time I could probably handle the administrative details.
Being a department chair, but it wasn't the be all and end all of my existence.
And so it was a pretty good fit.
And then after a few weeks after the interview, the dean called up to the offer me the
job, it was like 40th birthday.
And so it seemed like a, it seemed like an element of something.
And that was kind of amusing too, because I put in a call,
oh, this happened later on.
So I got the offer.
And then Kate and I weren't invited back to visit again at this time.
It was a recruitment visit.
And it was very pleasant again.
And then went back home and after a while thought things over and decided I would accept the job.
So I put in a call to the dean and he was out of the office.
And he would call back.
And I sat there thinking I was about to make a decision that would affect the rest of my life.
And the phone rang, and I thought it was Dean Kraus calling me back.
No, it was the guy from the Biochemistry Department of the University of California Davis.
Asking her if I'd like to be considered for the chairmanship of the department there.
And I said, you got a great department, but I think it's a little too late.
So what was the set of priority that you bought in the chairmanship?
The main priority for me to keep my research program.
Visible on productive.
It's quite a job to move research program.
I knew that the department would be in pretty good shape.
There were a few things that needed to be done.
You know, I knew I could handle whatever teaching I need to do here.
But not all the people that were working with me and Tucson chose to come.
So I had to punch more people.
And my major research grant had, I don't remember a year and a half or so to run.
And I just wanted to make sure that I got enough papers out during that time.
So I'd be competitive.
It was grants were already this now on the late 1970s.
The grant situation was taken into tight notes.
So that was my first priority.
You worked out pretty well.
Did administrative pressures change the design?
Yes.
But actually getting back to priorities for just a minute.
There were some things in the department early on that I felt should get taken care of.
One was the fact that the graduate students.
There was hardly any money in the department to support teaching assistants.
So there wasn't much state money that would support students who weren't committed to a lab.
So almost all of the students came on research assistants,
which aren't they were committed to the lab whose research grant was paying their assistantship.
And I thought that a first year graduate with programs should have opportunity for students to come on committed.
I thought it was a great strength that students could come here and start right to work with a person that they wanted to work with,
but that many students come without a specific set of interests.
And they should have an opportunity to go through rotation.
So pretty high priority for me early on was to get an NIH training grant that would provide funds for tuition and stipends for half of the students or so.
So that we could bring out a few and give them a year to look around and then go on to research assistantships.
And my first attempt was unsuccessful.
That was kind of interesting too because we got kind of a mediocre score on the grant application.
I'm really kind of a naughty critique in which the whoever reviewed the grants said the training record of the faculty doesn't seem to be particularly strong.
Most of the graduates seem to have taken jobs in industry.
And I wrote to the NIH and I said, what is this?
It seems to me that Congress, which funds the NIH might have second thoughts about the training grant program in industrial positions, they're seeing the second rate.
So I'm going to revise the application and I'd like to have a site visit.
So you can see what we have out here.
And so the second time we had a site visit and we got the grant and had it for two or three cycles.
That was a third of an institutional priority for me.
And then in 1981.
So this was an opportunity to sort of dumped in my lap, but it was an institutional priority for me.
The dean called me in and said that the MJ Murdoch charitable trust, you know about the Murdoch trust.
This is a large foundation that was created from the estate of Jack Murdoch who was one of the founders of Tectronics.
Murdoch died prematurely in an airplane accident.
And he left most of the state entrusted as a foundation to support educational charitable and community organizations, that's certainly more or less.
And they used to give project grants to faculty here.
But apparently the trust had told the president, we've figured that they now wanted to focus their grants more on large multi-person projects that represented institutional priorities.
And so the dean and the president and others then decided that he was time to make a push in molecular biology.
So they called me and as the person to sort of the point person to write something up.
And it was clear, that was right.
It was very much a time to make a push even though that doesn't pretty good people scattered around the university here in that area.
And it was clear to me that there's multi-departmental cooperation is very strong on this campus.
And so whatever we did should be in a multi-departmental, multi-disciplinary framework.
So I propose that the university creates something to be called a center-progene research.
And that the grant then fund three positions and pay their salaries and start-up costs for two years with the commitment by the university that their salaries would be continued at the end of that two years.
And that the search would be conducted in a multi-departmental framework.
There was old money also for project grants for the faculty that was here.
And so then we, when the grant was funded, we had a multi-departmental search that bought three excellent people in.
One who came to art department is now the chairman of art department, Gary Merrill.
One who went to botany, Carol Ruin.
And one who went to microbiology and I've done this really is now the chief scientist offered officer at the Siege Pharmaceutical, so very good people.
In the meantime, the people in the ag school wanted to form a biotechnology institute or biotechnology center.
And present, we figure told them that there wasn't a, that the campus wasn't big enough to have two competing centers and areas related to biotechnology.
And they'd better work with us.
So, so we made the center.
I mean, I had no idea it would grow to something that encompass the whole campus the way I did, but it turned out to be very successful.
And in the first several years, I think 1985, the center would call it on so well that the legislature appropriated a pretty fierce chunk of change as continuing a continuing budget for the, quite that time of the CGRB.
So, that was something else that worked out pretty well.
And then I served the director of the center for a year and a half or so after the first director of the web, the fairly abruptly.
But, well, it continued to get bigger and stronger and after, after I resigned as director because I couldn't handle.
Two administrator jobs and still keep a research lab going and keep my teaching going.
And so there was sort of an interim appointment made while there was an outside search and rust mines came from the University of Nebraska.
And he built it up a bit.
And then he retired and then it really big push came when Jim County was brought in.
And of course, he had a superb research program.
And so, I think his program attracted a lot of other people and departments all over the campus were beginning to use molecular biology techniques.
So, the center and then Jim changed the focus of the center with a big emphasis on genomics and computational biology.
In fact, the name of the center was changed. I didn't realize this for a couple years. It's still the CGRB.
But now instead of being the center for gene research and biotechnology, it's the center for genome research and bio computing.
And so, five or six years ago, there was the University wide hiring initiative in genomics and bio computing.
And there was another moly departmental search that I think brought five faculty members.
And they're outstanding people. One of them is the Michael Freytale you came through the art department and his office is right next door to mine.
And one is Todd Mochler and botanists and extremely well.
I think he left Carrington left this year to become president of director of the Danforth Foundation in St. Louis.
You know, I just learned it there too that Mochler went with him. But it really outstanding people came and that focused the center change.
And it's well rooted in the University of the Central Service Lab, which the center maintains.
It carries out multi-investigator procedures, nucleic acid sequencing and algal peptide synthesis that it's been doing for years.
But it also has a very large computational and second generation DNA sequencing capability grafted on.
So it's got bigger and stronger over the years.
So getting back to administrative responsibilities, how did they shift over the years?
They shifted in that it got harder and harder to get money.
And there was a little bit more administration that had to get done.
So the first year or two I was here.
One of my colleagues got money in one of his grants.
$100,000 to buy an electron microscope. This is one of our department was doing water at Hall.
And he came to me and said, we need a broom to put the luck on microscope.
And I said, well, I guess we're going to have to see the deans. We don't see Dean Cross.
And it was maybe a 15-minute conversation.
And he found $50,000 to renovate some space on the first floor of the wonder.
And so we got the pretty substantial amount of money on the basis of a short one short conversation.
And getting money became harder and harder at one point.
So our department was always been very heavily involved with the Environmental Health Science Center.
This is a center that's funded with a core grant from the National Institute of Environmental Health Sciences.
And it was originally headquartered basically in what used to be the Department of Agricultural Chemistry.
And that again, as a center that's become bigger and stronger over the years.
And at some point when the previous director retired, Dawn Reed, who was an art department, became the director of Civil War,
headling involved with that center. And one of the hardest things for me in my last several years of being departments here
was accumulating competitive start-up packages that's when we wanted to recruit a faculty member.
That's one thing to get a salary line.
But around the country, the amount of money you had to put together to attract someone.
It's getting larger and larger because a new assistant professor couldn't count on getting his or her first grant.
Funded and needed some money from day one.
And I remember one of the people who came in as a vice president for research, which is one of the major sources that we would go to.
I think I've suppressed his name because I dislike him so much.
Somehow or another, he never caught on to the idea that the discretionary funds he had as a disposal.
One of the highest priorities of him should be contributions toward set up on.
Then Dawn Reed was still the director of the, of the, the EHSC and I that, you know,
talk to yourself, blew in the face before we got a token contribution from him.
And we were just really irritated.
And I remember another interesting episode we had with the Environmental Health Science Center.
When Dawn Reed became director of the Center, this was in the early 1980s.
He also was pretty expansionist. He wanted to build and solidify the EHSC.
And this is our pan theoretical, but in my opinion, one of the strengths of Oregon State, they said something about the interdepartmental cooperation.
You have strong individual departments.
But these, you have the centers that that span departmental boundaries.
We have the CGRB.
The EHSC, and of course, the line is calling and suit.
And I think all of these centers have done nothing but good things for the university by bringing in more research strength.
The thing that Dawn Reed wanted to do was to use the funds he had in the center to establish two or three new
faculty positions that would be partly funded by the EHSC and partly funded by university funds.
So one of the positions would be in the order department.
You wanted to get someone who was using cell culture to study basically areas related to environmental toxicology.
And the dean at the time said, well, our department was over staffed already that we had too many faculty positions for the number of credit hours that we taught.
You know, the kind of thinking that the administrators goes through.
And the first bolt on and I saw this is a great opportunity to strengthen the department.
Research was and bring in some more money to the department.
And Dawn was pretty aggressive.
So he set up a.
So he set up a appointment and meeting with president and figure.
And six or eight of a sat around a table, including Dawn and myself.
And George Keller, who was the vice president for research in the time.
And Dean Suga Harrow, Dean of the College of Science and the president.
Maybe one or two others.
And Dean Suga Harrow went through his routine that the department was over staffed already.
And he couldn't justify putting even a part of his salary into our budget under the circumstances.
And then Dawn regave his pitch.
I don't think I said much about anything.
I was just there for support.
Dawn got all the negative brownie points from the dean.
And at the end of Dawn's talk.
Part of the figure said, let's sound like a pretty good proposal.
Let's go ahead with it.
And I thought the dean was going to cry.
And so at that from that point on Dawn reads name was poison in the college of science.
But it worked out very well.
He brought in David Barnes.
There's no longer here but that position was established.
And we got a research facility that's helped the whole campus community.
And then he brought in Dale Mosbau.
And what kind of was Adam Kim?
That Mosbau had a superb research program until he died very young in 2004.
But the idea that you could use center funds to strengthen research programs within departments.
And the strength and enter departmental cooperation has been a keynote for the CGRB, the EHSC, and the Linus Pauling Institute.
In fact, the early history of the Linus Pauling Institute is pretty interesting too.
Dawn Reed was acting director of the Institute while we had a search for director.
And I was chair of the search committee that brought bolts right here.
And that worked out extremely successfully.
Balls that's so good in the people he brought in are just outstanding.
But I think the only time I ever had a one-and-one conversation with President Richard was shortly,
while this was all underway.
I think I don't remember whether Balls ride or ride yet are still having research.
But, of course, it was concerned all over the campus about LPI.
How would drain research resources away from the administration?
And of course, the Linus Pauling Institute in California was pretty mixed with scientific equality.
And that was a bit of a concern.
But John Bern really pushed the whole thing.
It was his legacy to the university.
And we were, and so, Richard and I were walking together from some function.
And it was just the two of us.
And he said, what do you think about this move of the Linus Pauling Institute?
Anyway, he was pretty negative about the whole thing.
And I said, it doesn't make any difference.
What you were, I think about it.
It's happening anyway.
And at the time, I think I was one of the cautious ones about it too.
But I'd become nothing but a supporter.
Because we were so fortunate in getting balls to come here as our first choice.
I thought the recruitment would be very difficult because the LPI occupied space that our department
had occupied before we moved to the Agamilite Science.
And it was pretty, it was, the space was pretty trashed.
But, but both saw that it could work.
They did a little bit of renovation.
And of course, they said that a new building would be something that would be fairly high on the prior scale.
It took a long time, but it worked.
So you asked about the administrative load.
The other thing that happened in those last several years was the planning of the Agamilite Science
that took a lot of time.
And then in the initial planning, I became aware that there were documents in the university
that had five levels of space assignment depending on what kind of department or college you were in.
And of course, agriculture and forestry were on the highest level of number square feet per FTE of lab space, square feet per FTE for office space.
And science was a level below Ag.
And so we started having our first planning meetings.
And it was mostly Ag people, of course, because it was the Ag and life sciences.
And we were biochemistry by physics was put into the department sort of accidentally.
And the way I understood it was the administration was having trouble assembling funding for the building.
And it's all seriously, but the way I heard it was the George Keller said,
well, we don't have enough pizzazz in the building.
We have a range of science. We have ag administration.
We have horticulture that all, personally, justifiable.
But we need to put some of our environmental science.
We need to put some of our biotechnology in there.
And apparently, Dean Horne was at the planning meeting and he said, well, you know, biochemistry in bio physics.
He's heavily involved in both of the biotechnology and environmental health science.
So we were moved in very quickly.
But then it turned out that they wanted to assign us space on the science level of science.
And I figured if we're moving to the new building, we need to have the same kind of space allocation
that the other governments in the building had.
Is it about that time about that time of friend of mine who was chairman of the search committee
for Dean of science at Penn State invited me to come to look at the job.
And after I looked at it, I didn't want the job, but it was clear that they wanted me.
So I went to talk to Graham Spanner, of course, who would come here from Penn State.
And now as back there is one of the most successful university presidents in the country.
And Graham was very excited to hear that they wanted me to go to Penn State.
He didn't talk to me at all about what can we do to keep you.
He wanted to know a lot about what was happening at Penn State and so forth.
But he did eventually, you know, what would it take to keep you?
And I had two things in mind that would benefit the department.
And one of them was space allocation and building.
They said they're basically trying to talk and sound on space.
We have adequate space and one of your space is kind of second-rate quality was.
But if we're going to be asked to help plant a new building and move into space,
we need to.
We need to be assured that if we don't have to accept any less square footers, what we have now.
So he put that on a ladder that helped me a lot.
He's going to have to be the planning process.
But that took a lot of time too.
Were there any major shifts in your research in the years?
Yes, not major.
I've always been involved in nucleotide.
The oxygen nucleotide and DNA precursor in zymology.
But I can tell you, yeah, the answer is yes, I'll get to that in a minute.
But I'll tell you another story about the new building that you might want to entertain.
This has to do with the administrative load.
And you have to watch these guys all the time.
Actually, two stories.
One time we were meeting and the administration building.
And we were being told that there wasn't enough money to build a building with size.
That was being discussed in the beginning.
And we were going all around the table.
What can we do about this cutback?
And that cutback.
And it was getting pretty late in the country.
And the evening, you know, six o'clock, six or three or so.
And at the guy named Ed Coat was the vice president for the administration of the time.
And he was kind of a laughing sock in the faculty.
And he was getting more and more in a patient.
He basically said finally, hey, it's getting late here.
Let's just lock off a floor and we can leave.
So that's solidified our view.
But I quote, and somehow it ended up that the building was built.
I think the university got a bargain.
It's a very good building.
You know, it's done with the fund available.
But at one point, the architect told me that we've built a prototype laboratory.
So you and your colleagues can go over look at it.
Look at the cabinet.
Look at the shell.
Look at the bench top.
Look at the utility.
You can see what it looked like.
I said where it's in Moreland Hall.
There's a member of the psychology faculty.
Bill Smotherman, who does physiological work.
And he needed an upgrade to his lab.
So we've built that as a prototype lab.
And you can go and see what it looks like.
And so we went over and it did a nice lab.
And so we could see what kind of countertops they're going to have.
And then it occurred to me to ask someone, hey, where the money come from to do this.
It turns out that Bill Smotherman had been offered a job in another institution.
And he needed in order to stay.
One of the things that he needed was an upgrade to the labs.
So we went to his dean, the dean went to the then provost.
And somehow things are coming about.
So the money was siphoned out of our building project.
To build this guy's lab.
And so we raised hell about it.
And so they had to find the money from somewhere else and put it back in the building project.
So you had to be on your toes all the time about these guys.
So getting back to research.
I had a graduate student in the early.
Who finished in about 1982.
Who did his thesis on.
On the DNA precursor, she supplied for the mitochondrial.
A genome.
I'd seen a paper in the literature that suggested that.
The mitochondrial genome is fed by.
A distinct precursor pool that might be generated within the mitochondria.
And so.
Rick Bestwick did a thesis on the series of experiments.
And indicated yes indeed that the pools were physically.
And distinct and regulatory sense as well.
And then that sort of sat there until late 1990s.
And another grader of student joined our group.
She was a song.
Chinese student.
Who wanted to follow up on that.
He was a.
He had a medical degree from China.
And a number of diseases had been described that have.
That have a genetic.
Effects within the mitochondria.
And some of them are mutations within the mitochondrial genome.
Some of them are mutations in the nuclear.
Genome that encode proteins that are transported into mitochondria.
And function there.
And so that's some very interesting.
The disease.
And of course now there's also the.
The.
The idea that.
Immulation of mutations in the mitochondrial.
Genome is partly responsible for cancer and aging.
And since we knew that.
Aspects of DNA precursor metabolism.
Our mutagenic determinants.
That is metabolic.
Dearranged one.
But if you will.
Of a deoxinucytoid metabolism.
Can effect.
The mutation rate.
We wanted to learn more about the.
The mitochondrial pools of DNA precursor.
She's where they came from.
How they were regulated.
And how.
This might affect mutation rate.
It turns out the.
It's great for the mitochondrial genomes.
Much higher than it is for the nuclear genome.
And why should this be.
So she way did his thesis on this.
And he was one of my last.
Gradual students to finish.
But by the time he started publishing papers.
Mesthesis.
We began to get some notice for this.
So.
I got funding.
Actually after I retired.
And it was hoping I'd be able to keep.
Research funding going.
Because this was turning out to be a pretty productive one of research.
So.
So that.
In fact, that has been.
The total of our research since about.
2003.
And.
Had.
Pretty decent funding for that.
I'm during that time.
The three.
Gradual students that I had.
At the time.
I retired in 2002.
They took.
Two and three four years to finish.
And they were done.
But after that.
I kept my lab going with a technician and a postdoc.
And one or two undergrad was supposed to time.
Now I decided to.
So what my funding expire and what there's a new faculty number and our department is going to take over our lab.
So my last.
Grand expires.
And the year.
But for the last year.
Last year.
It's.
It's taking the.
Knowledge in the background.
I have.
The stage.
If the major tech snow.
I don't think no kids must go in notch.
But they got away.
And the gesehen devastating.
The most popular thing in the city is in this city.
I found this in the outside.
And we have two sort of dance level undergraduate, of course,
this BB-451, which most students say is a two-quarter sequence,
and then BB-494-901 and 492.
And these can both be taken as an undergraduate graduate.
And these two books came out.
And one of them we assigned is a 450-course,
and one we adopted for the 494, and they're both terrible.
At some point in the spring,
I was eating my lunch in my office,
and a publisher's representative came in,
and I sort of set my sandwich aside.
And so I told them how disappointed we were with all the textbooks
that were on the market.
And he said, well, you know, you know,
so much about what's wrong with all these books.
You ought to be writing your own book.
And I said, are you crazy?
I don't have the time or the expertise to write a whole book.
I said, well, get a co-author.
Well, I was about to go on sabbatical leave
to Sweden, and I thought, well, you know,
maybe I could write in the evening working a lot during the day.
So it's not a completely crazy idea.
And I was talking to my colleague, Bob Becker, about this.
And he said, well, why don't you talk to Ken Van Holt?
He's talked about writing textbooks from time to time.
And Ken and I had taught graduate,
but of course, it's together.
I knew he was extremely articulate and brilliant scientists.
And he had a good sense of humor.
And also was much more of a physical biochemist than I am.
His PhD is actually a physical chemistry.
So I went and talked to Ken and he said, well,
I have to be crazy to even think about something like this.
But yes, I am interested.
So we went down and visited the publisher and talked to our editor.
And she said that each of us should write a sample chapter.
And we should write a chapter outline.
And a prospectus sample chapter.
And she bought each of us a compact computer.
This is just before a Macintosh came out.
But there were slightly portable computers.
So I took one with me to Stockholm.
And by the way, it's not like that.
It's not like that.
It's slightly portable computer.
So I took one with me to Stockholm.
And by the time I had finished writing my sample chapter,
I thought this is more work on what I let myself in for.
But we sent the material in in December, Diane called up.
She said the reviewers all liked what we've written.
And they thought we ought to go ahead.
So they wanted scientists to contract.
So I thought, oh, God, what do I do now?
And he said, oh, yeah, I said, I think it's terrific.
Let's go.
So there was no alternative.
And we went ahead with it.
And many times during the writing process,
I thought I was crazy to get involved in this.
If I could quit, I would.
But in retrospect, I'm glad that we stuck with it.
And it took a long time because it was 1984 that they first started talking to us about the book.
It was early 85 when we signed the contract.
And then I had a lot of things that got me behind schedule when I came back from a sabbatical.
And we didn't really plunge into work on any kind of schedule basis to a spring or so of 1986.
But we had the first draft done.
Maybe in spring of 88.
No, I must have been.
I don't remember the dates now.
Because it took a year or so to produce the book after the after the chapter drafts were done.
So the whole thing was about a almost a five year process.
And the subsequent additions were much easier.
It was a difficult process.
There's that was the point of view of the two authors.
It was going to be writing something.
Actually, that was the easiest part.
Ken and I split up responsibility for chapters very easily.
We agreed to read each other chapters.
I did most of the metabolism.
He did most of the structural biochemistry.
And we sort of split the molecular biology to genetic biochemistry.
And the editors were very concerned about burzing our pros styles.
I think we did pretty well.
Although now that I'm writing some for our fourth edition, which he's not involved in,
I'm writing some rewriting some chapters he wrote.
And I'm seeing some differences between his writing style and mine.
But the difficulty we had in the first edition was simply spirited arguments with our editors.
They kept the pretty heavy hand on us.
And we disagreed with it pretty frequently.
But they ended up being pretty good friends.
And we had a different editorial team, each of the editions.
But that was where the energy came out.
But Ken and I had nothing but good relations.
The one thing he was all disappointing was that he spent almost half the year at his summer home.
He would hold that he established when he was at the University of Illinois before he came here.
And that's true.
So it wasn't always a matter of just walking down the hall if I wanted to talk to him.
But he worked out pretty well.
It did pretty well.
I can't tell you how much percentage of the market had captured.
But the publisher very pleased.
He in terms of the royalties we were very pleased.
And I've been told by quite a few people.
I mean, this is not something I should be talking about.
But I've been told that that is the most clearly written book on the market.
And I know it had brought us a lot of attention.
I know when I was in Svadical even Sweden.
I got a call one day.
And from someone at the University of Lipsaw, they wanted me to come and meet with a group of
their biochemistry teachers to tell them my thoughts about teaching biochemistry.
I gave a talk in South Africa a few years ago.
And their biochemistry meeting and the students were coming up and wanting to be photographing
because they'd used our book.
So a lot of things happened that were very gratifying and ego.
So from that standpoint, I guess our book was received well enough.
It was worth the effort and worth the effort after the project.
I thought it was dead after the third edition was done.
That it was worth picking up for the fourth edition.
As you look back on your career, what are some of the things you've posted?
I guess the first thing is the fact that I trained 35 PhD students.
And most of them have done very well on their careers.
And it's like being a parent.
And most of them have stayed in enough contact.
I have the feeling that I made a difference in their lives.
Another thing that I've been satisfied with is maintaining a balance of teaching and research through all the positions I've had.
Because I always enjoyed teaching.
I'm pretty enthusiastic about the field.
I like to know what's going on in the field.
I like to explain to others whether it's in writing or speaking.
And I like to set an example for colleagues who might be focused only on their research.
That you can be a successful research scientist and still maintain personal communication with students,
with colleagues, with people and other departments on the campus.
That science can be a social activity.
So I would say the breadth of interest and association that has something else I take satisfaction in.
And being able to save funded for years and a very difficult, increasingly difficult environment.
And the book.
I mean, that's a pretty big part of my life.
A pretty big strain in our family situation for a long time.
But now Kate is just supportive about the whole thing as I am.
She likes it when I come home and tell her stories about experience that we had.
So it's been a big plus also.
Is there anything that we missed that we missed on?
Well, yeah, I guess there's always been the thought about what, again, parallel.
Whereas parallel universes.
What if I go on into medicine?
And that's hit at several times when I was in college trying to decide which way to go.
Of course my father was a doctor.
I thought the world of them.
And I talked in a kid and maybe we could go out of practice together.
And that could have been fun.
But dad was very good about not putting pressure on.
He said it was my decision whether to go on the science or medicine.
And the U.S. about the red college culture earlier.
And premeds were sort of frowned on as being grade lovers.
Even though we gave grades, but the students weren't told what the grades were.
And the idea was to make you less grade causes.
But the premeds were a little more narrow on their interests.
And I saw that I was something about the culture that the highest level of acceptance
was the people that wanted to go on and be university and college professors.
So that helped.
And then I was pointed in that direction.
But when I went to Arizona and started teaching medical students,
I realized that biochemistry in that context is a lot different.
And my father had actually never actually conveyed to me the intellectual stimulation of medicine
as a multi-depart metal scientific activity.
It was partly, he was in practice.
He was an internist.
But a lot of his patients were, it did have routine troubles that didn't give him much stimulation.
So he didn't convey that part of it.
But once I had to learn to teach biochemistry in a way that medical students would accept.
And once I started interacting with MD college, I realized that medicine is a lot different from what I thought I was.
And so at some point after I had been there a few years, early 70s,
I read that the University of Miami had created a fast track MD program for PhDs in the biomedical sciences.
You could finish a MD degree in a year and a half to two years.
I was pretty interested in this.
So I applied for it.
And it was accepted.
And then I went to talk to the department chairman.
The idea being that one of the years, I could get partial support by being on sabbatical lead.
And then we'd use it on resource for the rest.
And when I told him about it, he looked though he'd been kicked in the stomach.
And then he talked to my colleagues, which I always felt was improper.
I thought that my conversation was just one or one.
But after a week, he said that the department decided they really didn't want me to do this.
Well, obviously I could have done it anyway.
But I would have had to resign.
I could have resigned.
And I thought it over.
And by that time our children were dating 10, we were pretty well settled and two son.
And there wasn't any, and I enjoyed what I was doing.
There wasn't any real, there wasn't any reason that I had to do this.
But I've always wondered what it would have been like if I'd had a career in medicine.
What would I have gone into medical research?
What would I have been a primary land in practice?
What would I have gotten the intellectual stimulation?
Would I have enjoyed the kind of bread the awareness of what's happening in cutting edge science?
And all the rest of it would be nice if you could live two lives.
But that's something I just have to live with, I guess.
So obviously we're also very proud of our two children.
Lawrence, who was, as I said, was born very shortly after our marriage.
And then, and it was born a couple years later.
Lawrence ended up going to the University of Washington for a PhD in biochemistry.
So he was in the same department I was.
And the department had changed a lot since then.
He's now out of science, but he got a great start to his career.
He did a postdoc in Sweden, and then a second postdoc in the sockets to it.
And he did a piece of work that made him quite well known.
And he had, he had four excellent faculty offers.
And he was in a system professor at the University of Michigan for several years.
And he had an epiphany.
And now he's a teacher in the Walter school system.
And we'll go into detail about that.
He is much happier doing that than ever was as a university faculty member.
And our daughter graduated from Oregon State with a degree in psychology.
And no clue to what she wanted to do.
And she happened to talk to a naval recruiter on campus.
And ended up going to naval officer candidates school after she graduated and becoming an
Anson. And she did very well in the Navy.
But she ended up secretly getting married to an unlisted and under her command.
And that was a no-no in the Navy.
And when they found out they were both in trouble.
And again, making a long story short, they both left the Navy.
And the Ann was in the reserve.
She got promoted in the reserve.
So she was in good standing as far as the Navy was concerned.
But they had two children.
And she was basically soccer mom.
And two daughters were in college.
And then she went back.
And got a degree as a as a paralegal assistant.
So she's working at field.
So both of our children are doing things.
They enjoy great deal.
Each of them has two children who've done very well.
And so that's something that Kate and I can look at with some satisfaction.
Also.